bonjour et bienvenue à diagonale la
leçon en ce lundi 15 mai 2000
alors aujourd'hui je suis tout seul pour
présenter cette émission mais ce n'est
pas grave puisque l'émission sera de
bonne qualité quand même la dernière
fois donc lundi lundi 17 17 avril oui
puisqu'il et trois lundi férié depuis
nous avons vu comment gagner la position
enfin les finales élémentaire roi plus
d'âme contre roy au roi plus tour contre
roy et ainsi de suite
alors une fois que vous savez gagner
avec avec ça c'est à dire avec juste une
pièce qui suffit une pièce lourde
une dame ou tour on peut revenir plus
plus plus en avant et gagner avec
simplement un pion puisqu'il suffira
d'amener ses options adam est ainsi donc
vous aurez roi et dames contre roy et la
partie va gagner donc en fait aux échecs
pour gagner une partie il suffit d'un
pion avantages que vous pouvez acquérir
dans le milieu de jeu dans l'ouverture
en tout cas c'est quelque chose qu'on
fait fructifier et on arrive en finale
la fameuse finale roi epyon contre
eurois donc cette finale
bien entendu est complexe il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de cas est étudié beaucoup
beaucoup de cas va être tout à fait et
notamment le cas le plus simple c'est
qu'on le pion avance tout seul et que le
roi adverse ne peut pas l'arrêter alors
on va tout de suite passé sur le sur
l'écran avec un premier exemple premier
exemple très simple vous voyez que les
blancs ont un roi en a deux les noirs
ont le roi henri iv et les blancs ont
juste cette petite différence ce sera le
thème de l'émission d'aujourd'hui un
pion de plus ce qui est tout seul sur
cette case f4 alors qu'est-ce que ça
qu'est-ce que ça entraîne et bien le
pion aux libres d'avancé et d'ailleurs
le roi noir a l'air assez loin c'est le
premier cas qu'on va étudier le roi noir
est trop loin et il suffit donc aux
blancs d'avancé le pion en jouant f5 les
noirs reviennent sur le pion avec roy b5
on continue à avancer franchement f6 roi
ses six f-16 et là on s'aperçoit que le
roi ne peut pas arriver pour arrêter le
tueur il peut jouer roi 17 mai les
blancs c'est pas grave il continue il
jouait fuite promotion dame est là après
reportez-vous à l'émission du 17 avril
pour savoir exactement comment gagner 7
parti donc ça c'est le premier exemple
tout l'enjeu de la position est de
savoir si le pion va arriver à dame ou
non alors on va revenir au début et donc
c'est un cas où l'option blanc et
éloignées on est bien d'accord
le pion blanc est éloigné de l'action il
est sur la colonne f alors que les deux
rois sont complètement à gauche de
l'échiquier
alors comment savoir immédiatement si
cette position est gagnante ou nuls
c'est à dire qu en fait l'enjeu est très
simple c'est le roi noir avait un temps
date de plus c'est à dire que si les
blancs joué par exemple 3 b2 qui perd un
temps dans cette position les noirs jour
et roye b 4 et cette fois ci n'aurait
plus qu'à aller manger le pion
puisqu'après f5 leroy revient ainsi de
suite on continue sauf que là puisque
les bleus ont perdu un temps au début de
variantes le roi noir arrive juste à
temps pour manger ce pion là plus rien à
faire on ne peut plus défendre
et si on lave ans pour faire promotion
dame pareil au roi prend dame donc ici
la partie évidemment déclarés nuls donc
reprenons au début vous voyez cette
position là qu'est ce qui va vous faire
dire si la partie est gagnante au nul et
bien c'est très simple c'est ce qu'on
appelle le carré du pion alors on va
former avec ses pions on va l'amener sur
la diagonale en diagonale on la mène
jusqu ici et là en forment un carré
entre la case diagonale et la casse du
kg ont donc à vous voyez toutes les
classes vertes cette délimite les cases
ou si le roi noir était dedans il
pourrait stopper le pion donc si c'est
au noir de tous et bien entendu le roi
noir rentre dans le carré du pion entre
sur une des cases verte et là va arrêter
les pions comme malheureusement ou
heureusement pour les blancs
c'est à vous de jouer ils avancent leurs
pions un temps en avance maintenant on
peut voir le nouveau cas réduction donc
on reforme en corse est ce petit schéma
avec un carré comme ça et là on voit
bien que les noirs ne peuvent pas
rentrer dans ce quart est donc tout
simplement la position de la position de
départ ici après un f5 c'est le cas
numéro un ce cas là est gagnant si c'est
hollande j'aurais nuls 6 et au noir de
jouer donc ça c'est un premier exemple
donc on va tout de suite en voir un
deuxième sur ce carré du pion là
effectivement on va former le carré et
on va s'apercevoir très très vite
donc là que je ne vous fait plus les
cases annexes que le roi noir est dedans
donc là c'est aux blancs de jouer il
avance laurent noir revient et attrapes
évidemment le pion évidemment puisque de
le carré étant de plus en plus petits
mais le roi noir est toujours dedans
donc là ils arrêtent rupture donc ça
c'est le premier premier exemple les
premières positions ou simplement le roi
blanc et or de l'action hors de l'action
puisqu'il ne peut pas venir y participer
le pion blanc est tout seul dans un coin
éloigné de l'échiquier et le roi noir va
essayé de l'attrapper donc la très très
simple de toute façon les coûts cool de
même il n'y a pas de choix pour les deux
camps simplement évidemment si on
calcule cette histoire de quart et on
voit tout de suite si l'option va être
attrapé ou pas l'autre méthode est temps
de calculer brut c'est à dire voilà le
pion avance le roi bien là le plus en
avance le roi revient là ce qui est plus
long et moins intuitif voilà donc deux
exemples dans le premier exemple le roi
noir n'arrête pas le pion dans le
deuxième il arrive juste au bon moment
ça fait deux possibilités donc voilà on
a vu ce premier cas où le roi blanc
n'intervient pas maintenant on va voir
quand même que ça marche beaucoup mieux
quand on a froid et pion contre roy
c'est à dire que le roi blanc est aussi
dans l'action c'est notre prochain
exemple ici et là ça c'est plus
compliqué vous voyez les deux les droits
sont au centre et avant de commencer à
étudier cette finale je vais vous
présenter le principe de l'opposition
principe très très connue c'est les deux
rois sont en opposition
donc ils sont comme ça l'un en face de
l'autre
et quand un roi se déplace d'une case
sur la droite par exemple l'autre roi va
garder l'opposition se déplaçant
également sur la droite devant lui ce
qui donne sur l'échiquier ici par
exemple premier coup donc c'est aux
blancs de jouer c'est une tentative aura
c4 et la non là c'est voilà les noirs
peuvent garder l'opposition en jouant au
fc 6 donc ça c'est une juste une idée
d'opposition
si les blancs venaient en b3 il y aurait
trois baies 5
donc là c'est un exemple en faisant
complètement abstraction du pions blancs
et on voit que ça ça va enfin en
d'ailleurs ne voit on voit juste on voit
pas grand chose pour l'instant puisque
on voit simplement que les droits sont
l'un en face de l'autre
et qu'est ce que ça fait ça fait trois
cases contrôlé par les deux rois trois
cases de vis-à-vis est en fait le
principe de l'opposition c'est que si un
roi c'est d'une de ces cases l'autre roi
immédiatement y aller donc dans quand
les droits sont en vis-à-vis le roi qui
va jouer va forcément cd15 halo 3 ça
c'est un principe très très important
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'opposition
prendre l'opposition c'est se mettre en
face de l'autre roi
et le forcer à nous concéder des cases
donc revenons sur la position de départ
ici les droits sont en opposition comme
c'est au plan de jouer on peut dire que
le dernier coup des noirs a été de
mettre leurs rouen des six est de
justement prendre cette fameuse
opposition ici tentatives pour gagner
trois c4 donc très vite contré par les
noirs qui joue le roi en a eu cinq
attaques le pion forçant donc
complètement la défense des blancs roi
des 3 et maintenant les noirs repartent
derrière le piano enfin toujours devant
lyon le principe de défense quand vous
avez cette finale roy action contre roy
c'est à dire que le roi noir et devant
le pion blanc et le roi blanc et à côté
du pian blanche
il faut toujours rester devant
évidemment si le roi par par derrière
s'ils s'aventurent plus loin qu'il ne
peut dans la position le pion n'aura
plus qu'avant c'est donc le renoir doit
rester dans le pion les blanches au roi
des 4 et la très important les noirs
prennent l'opposition avec trois des six
ici il n'ya pas d'autre choix pour les
blancs que d'avancer leurs pions c'est à
dire que si on commence à jouer de
travers c'est à dire voir ces quatre ou
trois ans c'était à partir sur les cases
annexes qui sont ici on perdra
immédiatement le contrôle de la case au
5 et le roi ne s'aventurera dessus et
obtiendra un poste là intéressant donc
on avance nokia e5 laurent noir restant
de 6,3 blanc veut 4 hélas ici un très
bon coup joué par les noirs c'est le bon
réflexe dans cette position il faut
aller sur la case eaux cette
il faut venir sur cette case là alors je
veux faire un petit retour en arrière
dans cette position il est très
important de venir sur la case ici qui
est en fait devant le pion toujours
parce que si on vient sur une autre case
ses terres si par exemple on venait sur
les cases 17
ce ne serait pas précis parce que ça
permettrait aux blancs de prendre ce
qu'on appelle cette fameuse opposition
donc il faut éviter en finale d'euro
action contre roye de donner à son
adversaire la chance de mettre son roi
en face du vôtre c'est exactement ce que
font les noirs dans cette position là
puisqu'ils viennent sur la case hausse
est hélas les blancs ne peuvent pas
prendre l'opposition puisque ils ont
l'option blanc leurs propres pions qui
les bloque qui les empêche d'y aller
donc toujours le bon réflexe quand votre
adversaire est en train d'avancer on ne
peut pas l'empêcher d'avancer avec roy
et pions il faut se décaler il faut
reculer
face aux pions c'est le meilleur moyen
de défendre trois des cinq donc la très
très facile on a plusieurs cartes on a
le choix entre six cases 5 4 seulement
mais évidemment avec l'habitude y en a
plus qu'une seule qui nous intéresse
c'est la case qui se met en face de
l'autre roi des rois 17e six échecs 3,7
donc là on se met toujours devant le
pion c'est la règle de base les blancs
n'ont pas le choix et doit jouer euro 5
et ici de la défense précise évidemment
même l'unique défense maintenant dans
cette position c'est de jouer roi en 1 8
donc même thème qu'avant les blancs
juste avancé d'une case et maintenant le
roi va 2e set en 1/8 et ici la seule
tentative des blancs il y en a deux en
fait ces rois des 6 3 6 donc regardons
d'abord leroy qui vient sur le côté
droit
les noir reprennent l'opposition qui ont
poussé cheikh roi en 8es ici les blancs
sont devant un curieux problème c'est à
dire que s'ils s'en vont n'importe où
ils vont perdre l'option donc il n'y a
qu'une seule case qui leur permet de
garder la défense de ce pion c'est la
case aux 6es là qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est tout simplement pâte pattes parce
que le roi est l'option blanc contrôler
toutes les cases
c'est l'option contrôler les deux cases
rouges ici en fuite et des 8 es le roi
contrôle les trois cases qui sont face à
l'entrepôt donc ici c'est la position de
pâte qui est l'unique ressource
défensive des noirs dans cette finale
depuis le début donc reprenons quand
même depuis le début cette finale on
voit cette position là le roi noir lui
un cheminement extrêmement simple c'est
à dire que pour se défendre dans cette
position qui est nul il faut rester
toujours devant le pion et quand le roi
blanc via un côté du pion se mettre face
à lui ce qui donne là vous allez voir
c'est très très logique roi des trois là
on reste devant le pion les blancs
tentent de progresser
évidemment les blocs on se met face à
eux le pion avance on reste toujours
devant le pion c'est très simple roy 4
maintenant il faut une fois de plus
partir sur la case donc rester dans cet
axe l'acce du pion c'est capital dans
cette finale trois des cinq très facile
maintenant on se met en face du roi aux
six échecs
donc là il ya toute une mécanique
et qui est très très simple en fait qui
est toujours la même un étage plus haut
re5 3,8 au roi donc là on l'autre
possibilité aurait été roi des 620
bureaux à m6 la dernière fois et là on
ne va pas en réfute évidemment puisque
ça permettrait à l'autre de faire dame
en viande ebit de 7 3 8 et maintenant
comme ya plus de on ne peut plus avancer
on ne peut plus reculer
c'est tout simplement date est donc nul
donc voilà un premier exemple de cette
finale rois des pions contre roi le roi
blanc à côté de son propre pions et là
le roi noir doit rester toujours dans
laxe ou alors se mettre face au roi
blanc quand celui ci vient à côté de
sanctions maintenant un autre exemple
nouvel exemple de cette même finale qui
cette fois ci n'est plus la même chose
alors pourquoi ce n'est plus pareil
puisque ça ressemble vraiment beaucoup
et bien là une différence extrême c'est
que le roi blanc peut passer devant son
propre pions et c'est ça le moyen de
gagner dans cette finale donc c'est ce
qu'on va voir tout de suite le bon coup
dans cette position ces 3 e 4 alors
qu'est ce qui se passe ici c'est les
blancs qui prennent l'opposition cette
fois ci ils ont leurs pions derrière
leurs pions qui est en retrait et ça
c'est très important alors maintenant
vous voyez ce que ce que je disais au
départ c'est qu'on prend le contrôle de
ces trois cases la d34 verte c'est ton
noir de jouer et quelle que soit leur
coup ils vont être obligés de concéder
une de ces cases et ça c'est un gros
problème pour les noirs c'est un très
gros problème dans cette position
puisque après 3 des 6 le roi blanc
évidemment profite de cette de cette
concession
et donc il bondit sur la case f5 le roi
noir donc doit reculer pour justement
rester devant lyon puisque s'il s'en
aller y aurait plus aucun
il n'y aurait plus aucune idée défensive
l'idée défensive et quand même
d'empêcher le pion d'aller à dame
c'est tout l'enjeu des finales euro
action contre roy sait si l'option
arrive adams et gagner donc ici recettes
on reste devant le pion et là vous voyez
qu'on ne va pas avancer notions tout de
suite puisque ça serait une faute grave
je veux 4 dans cette position après roy
f7 les noirs récupère l'opposition est
ici il n'ya plus moyen d'avancer re 5 3
au 7
c'est ce qu'on a vu la dernière fois on
va montrer très très vite cette variante
puisque maintenant vous devez déjà être
habitué
trois des cinq rois 17 pas moyen de s'en
détacher aux cinq là on reste devant le
pion aux 6 on reste devant le pion roi
des six trois des huit avec le fameux
pacte qui arrivent eux cette roue à 8
016 donc variant du rapidement puisque
c'est exactement la même que la dernière
fois sur wyeth il ne faut pas avancer le
pion sinon ça serait tout simplement
partie nulle on joue au roi a eu 5 on
recommence on recommence exactement la
même chose sauf que là on a gagné une
case on est un cran au dessus et notre
champ est toujours derrière et ça s'est
très très bien il faut toujours avoir le
roi devant le pion on le rappellera
jamais assez en finale l'option weitz
est donc là le roi noir est parti à
droite
donc on en profite évidemment pour
passer sur la gauche trois des six roi 8
roubles 6 on continue on reprend encore
l'opposition une dernière fois
roy d'éviter maintenant c'est l'heure
d'avancer le pion aux 4 laura noir doit
rester en face à eux cinq là on arrive
donc la photo sur cette position
c'est vraiment une position de base une
position élémentaire quel que soit le
trait la position est gagnante
il se trouve que cette renoir roi et
fuite regardez cette très très logique
c'est un coût qui ne se commente même
plus tout simplement ici à l'opposition
le renoir de cheese je dois choisir son
côté doit choisir son camp et de toute
façon le roi blanc ira dans l'espace
créé de l'autre côté droit il suit 3 17
c'est un exemple très simple bref cette
est alors maintenant là on arrive dans
une position typiques leroy contrôle les
trois cases diop du les trois cases du
pion les trois casques le pion doit
franchir pour arriver
il suffit donc de l'avancé sans se
soucier des coûts noir de 6,3 et 6,7 au
f5 de toute façon il n'y a plus de
défenses huit dames
et maintenant c'est très simplement
gagnant en se référant simplement dans
les différer de diagonale la leçon à
l'édition du 12 avril vous saurez tout
de suite comment gagner trois dames
contre roy donc c'était un nouvel
exemple de cas de cas avec trois actions
contre le roi donc pour résumer tout ça
si le pion blanc le pion avance devant
le roi et que le roi noir est en phase
de ce pion la position et deux nuls pour
défendre c'est très simple il suffit de
rester avec son roi devant le pion et de
prendre l'opposition quand c'est
possible
maintenant le moyen de gagner la finale
roi étions contre roy c'est de passer le
roi devant le pion de prendre
l'opposition de gagner du terrain c'est
à dire d'avancé avec le roi d'abord
rencontrera en avance et ensuite pour
finir à mener pions vers la vers la case
de promotion vers la vie diamant voilà
donc on va passer à un nouveau cas le
pion h
le fameux pions h ce pion est très
spécial très particulier puisqu'il est
donc sur le sur la bande de l'échiquier
alors ici position de départ extrêmement
simple les deux rois sont en opposition
ce qui veut dire en fait quand on voit
cette position que le roi blanc pietrus
ne participera vraisemblablement pas
trop à la partie puisqu'il bloqué par
son homologue noir qui étend à 3 donc le
roi blanc ne jouera pas un rôle
déterminant ici l'enjeu de cette
position s'est une fois de plus cela
vous voyez tout de suite qu'on est donc
dans le premier cas qu'on a vu c'est le
pion est éloigné et le roi est très loin
aussi
donc là simplement c'est très simple ce
qui se passe dans cette position est ce
que le pion vadam ou non donc comme
c'est au grand jour et ils jouent h 2 h
4 et là on va refaire un petit qu un cas
réduction juste pour vous rappeler
comment ça marche
le cas réduction ici
voilà et le roi noir donc on voit très
bien qu'il est très très loin d'entrer
dans le carré on va quand même montrer
ce qui se passe si se dépêchent de
revenir vers le pion il va évidemment
arrivé trop tard puisque chaque camp ne
joue qu'une fois par coup et là tout
simplement
les blancs jouent h 7 h 8 dames et ces
gagnants
toujours cette fameuse émission du 17
avril qui est très très importante
décidé donc ce premier cas d'option h
on voit que quand les rois sont éloignés
c'est à dire c'est là c'est simplement
la règle du carré la première est qu'on
a vu aujourd'hui maintenant nouveau
qu'avec le pion âge qui est cette fois
ci plus compliqué le roi noir étant à
schmitt c'est à dire que le roi noir est
vraiment très très loin il est sur la
case de promotion prévue du pion leroy
plan étant le 4 et le pion blanc est en
hd
donc si ce n'avait si donc si ce pion h
avait justement été sur une autre
colonne sortait gagnant de façon très
simple il aurait suffit d'amener le roi
de prendre l'opposition
ensuite une fois qu'on contrôle
pratiquement la casse de promotion de
pousser les pions et c'était gagnant ici
avec le pion h il ya des gros problèmes
c'est à dire que tout simplement cette
position est nul
alors c'est ce qu'on va voir roy f5 ont
fait exactement la méthode qu'on a
mentionné précédemment
on amène le roi d'abord wash cette
rangée 5 et les noirs pour la défense
est extrêmement simple il suffirait sur
les cases h 8 et g 8 et on ne peut pas
les en déloger
alors voyons ce qui se passe donc on
continue selon la fameuse méthode
d'abord le roi ensuite le pion roger
vite et maintenant on avance le pion h4
roa schmitt h5
tout semble se passer comme dans le plan
roger vite et ici voilà c'est la pensée
aperçu du problème c'est quand les noirs
jour j'ai vite on ne peut pas passer de
l'autre côté on ne peut pas passer à
droite pour une raison très simple c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de case l'échiquier d'en
couper l'échiquier faisant 8 / vite
c'est indiscutable on ne peut pas aller
sur la casse dont qui serait ici y 7
puisqu'elle n'existe pas donc on est
obligé de rester face au roi les
noir-jaune-rouge suite et on n'a pas de
plan pour progresser dans cette position
tout simplement
donc on joue h 6
ranger 8h cette roche 8 et l'a donc une
fois de plus le même dilemme que
précédemment soit le roux un kit la
défense du pion est à prévoir profession
c'est nul soit les planches pour voir si
c'est cette fois ci ses pattes une
nouvelle fois obligatoire le roi
contrôlant les cases g7 et h7 est
l'option contrôlant la case à chocs 8 e
g8
donc ici tout simplement un pat cela de
toute évidence la position n'est pas
gagnante cette position n'a pas gagné
donc ça c'est l'option h quand le roi
noir et c'est une règle avec le pion à
quand le roi noir et devant le pion il
est sur la casa suite c'est toujours nul
et c'est la même chose évidemment pour
le pion à qui est en fait linverse
simplement le côté gauche au lieu du
côté droit donc très très simple les
conclusions de cette finale quand le roi
adverse le roi noir se trouve face aux
pions se trouve devant le pion sur la
case de promotion quand ils contrôlent
la case à chocs huit g8 ou f8 votre pion
h ne gagnera pas donc sachez le en
finale le pion quand le pion et sur la
bande il est sur le côté de l'échiquier
c'est beaucoup plus dur de gagner avec
alors qu'un pion central ou un pion même
qui est donc sur les cases des fous des
cavaliers va gagner beaucoup plus
souvent dans beaucoup plus de cas de
figure sagan ira maintenant
nouvel exemple avec le pion h et dernier
exemple donc on va pas s y passer tout
de suite ici
les noirs viennent de jouer roy en fuite
qu'on voit que les blancs sont bien
avancés dans cette position ils ont déjà
l'option qu'il a donc l'idée est bien
sûr d'empêcher le roi noir d'atteindre
ces fameuses gascon a cité avant les
cages éviter la fuite
parce qu'une fois qu'il est dessus sa
défense est très simple il a plus qu'à
rester dessus et on ne peut plus avancer
à cause du pat donc l'idée blanche et
dire je vais jouer maintenant rouages
tête donc là à priori
j'empêche le roi noir devenir sur ces
cases là je contrôle la case de
promotion de mon pions donc on ne voit
pas ce qui va empêcher d'en gagner dans
cette finale apparemment ça ressemble un
gain élémentaire et pourtant non puisque
après roy f7 3,8
c'est un exemple le roi noir cette fois
ci yves a utilisé un stratagème
défensive très très intéressant il a
joué roi et fuite
il va en fait coller le roi blanc dans
ce coin de l'échiquier dans ce coin du
ring et le roi blanc ne peut plus
maintenant se dégager pour laisser
passer son pion c'est ce qu'on va voir
donc on recommence rush 7
on rêve 7 et par exemple on essaie
d'avancer le pion puisque là il n'y a
plus moyen de sortir de la boîte h6 là
et noir reviennent en effet 8 c'est la
casse clé la casa fuite dans les finales
avec plonge une fois que vous l'avez
atteindre vous disposez des deux
méthodes
la première est celle qu'on élit menacé
d'aller manger vite pour faire nul et la
deuxième est celle qu'on voit en ce
moment même c'est à dire le roi en effet
cette ici donc après rouages suit trois
sets
on empêche le roi blanc de sortir de sa
boîte est suracheté est toujours roi et
fuite
et cette fois ci ce ne sont plus les
blancs qui provoque le pat mais les
noirs puisque les blancs n'ont plus de
couilles se sont fait complètement
enfermé le pion ne peut plus avancer et
le roi ne peut plus sortir puisque les
cartes sont contrôlés donc ici tout
simplement on a vu les deux stratagème
défensif on va revenir encore une fois à
cette position là après roy et suite ici
deux choix pour les blancs de choix dans
cette position soit allé sur la case à
chocs qui est en haut soit allé sur la
case justice qui est à gauche et dans
les deux cas de figure les blancs
n'arriveront pas à passer donc on
recommence sur roy g6 ici la défense
c'est les noirs maintenant qu'ils vont
prendre la position devant le pion qui
vont jouer roi j'évite les blancs n'ont
plus d'autre choix que de jouer h cet
échec
ou sinon de toute façon ça ne servira à
rien ça ne progressera plus rouach vite
et maintenant rage 6 avec le fameux
pattes
premier exemple donc si si dans cette
position après roy et fuite
les blancs décide de venir sur la case
g6 là à ce moment là on voit bien que
c'est des noirs qui prennent possession
des cases de promotion du pion et c'est
fini maintenant deuxième cas les blancs
disent je vais moi-même allé en
hashemite là les noirs ne doivent pas
partir ne doivent pas se laisser
distraire
ils doivent enfermé le roi blanc sur
cette case simplement jean roy et 7h
sète hérault à 8 créant le réseau de
pâtes
donc alors maintenant pour conclure
cette finale c'est finale avec le pion h
il faut impérativement pour gagner avec
un pion h m notre roi sur la case g7
c'est à dire empêcher le roi noir de
revenir sur la case f8 cette case f8
c'est la case clé une fois qu'il y ait
ça lui donne les deux possibilités
défensives qui est soit d'aller
directement devant le pion soin
d'enfermer notre roi dans la boîte et
avec ces deux possibilités là une fois
qu'il est en fuite
il n'y a plus moyen de gagner donc pour
cela pour éviter ça il faut mettre le
roi en g7 ou autre possibilité
envoyez le pion avant que le roi adverse
ne puisse arriver dans le carré et ça
c'est le gain le plus élémentaire
donc en général des finales avec pioche
sont nulles et en général les finales
avec pion central sont gagnantes et on
va conclure là dessus avec une dernière
position qui est une étude de monsieur
troïtski donc un des plus grands un des
plus grands compositeurs d'études de
tous les temps qui a fait des très
belles études et qui s'est notamment
intéressé à la finale deux cavaliers
contre pions alors mon petite parenthèse
qui va être très très courte avec roy et
de cavaliers on ne peut pas mater un roi
tout seul par contre avec roy et deux
cavaliers
quand notre adversaire à roye plus pions
on peut gagner donc c'est un peu
paradoxal puisque on rajoute du matériel
d'autres adversaires et c'est ce qui
permet de gagner
donc monsieur trotsky c'est très très
intéressé à cette pression roi et de
calais contre roy et pions il a
découvert dans certains cas que c'était
gagnant mais il a surtout composée des
merveilleuses études et notamment celle
ci donc là on est à la fin d'une étude
évidemment ça a commencé il ya quelques
coups déjà ça va nous permettre de
revenir sur un des thèmes qu'on a déjà
vu dans diagonale la leçon premier coup
dans cette position donc on voit qu'un
cavalier un roi une dame un roi un pion
donc pour l'instant on sort du cadre de
roi et qui ont entre roy mais ça va nous
permettre de rappeler un des principes
qu'on a déjà vu dans la leçon qui est le
principe de la fourchette la fourchette
ou blatak douillet plus généralement la
tacc double ici au premier coup on joue
cavalier c6 le cavadee vient ici attaque
le roi et la dame
donc il fait échec au roi et en même
temps attaque la dame le roi vient sur
la case des 5 par exemple
maintenant le cavalier prend la dame
tout simplement
calais prend dame au roi prend dame
alors après c'est donc ces deux coups
d'introduction on arrive dans la finale
roi epyon contre le roi est ici alors là
donc je vais vous laisser réfléchir
quelques secondes dans cette position
quel est le bon coup est-ce qu'il faut
avancer les pions ou m leroy devant le
pion alors effectivement en région dit
qu'il faut avancer le pion ce qui est
évidemment la faute puisque ici il faut
jouer d'abord le roi et ensuite le pion
donc c'est ce qu'on avait vu en début
d'émission
il fallait jouer roi f3 c'est un
principe que philidor a mentionné depuis
le xviiie siècle
sauf erreur de ma part roy f3 toujours
le roi avant le pion maintenant roi ou 5
et là on est dans le plan le plan
gagnant on n'a plus qu'à tracer c'est
l'autoroute
vous connaissez déjà cette position
roger iv le roi noir revient à m6
ici on prend l'opposition c'est très
très simple grossistes donc si ça veut
dire qu'on a pris l'opposition il est
obligé de se décaler on passe de l'autre
côté rocher 5
rolf sept rois f5 on continue on revient
dans cette opposition toujours roi g7
roi aussi son continu en continu d'abord
le roi et ensuite le pion donc là c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment bien et bien et
bien montrer puisque une fois qu'on a
repoussés le roi noir jusqu'aux limites
de son camp c'est à dire ce jusqu'à la
huitième rang j'ai là c'est l'heure
maintenant on y va on avance le pion f4
roi et fuite
f5 le roi noir doit choisir son côté il
vengé vite
rome 7 et là c'est très simple on
contrôle les trois cases donc quelles
que soient les coûts noir vous allez
avancer votre pion c'est très simple
donc ici revenons juste sur la position
de départ de cette étude
après donc dans cette position-là
position normalement perdante pour les
blancs puisque les noirs ont une dame de
plus tout simplement on joue qu'avec ses
six échecs fourchette
ensuite on ramasse la dame c'est à dire
qu'on a simplifié la position dans une
finale roi lion contre roy est ici très
très simplement le bon réflexe n'est pas
d'avancer le pion puisque ça serait nul
immédiatement c'est de passer droit
avant le pion et c'est ce qui va vous
permettre de gagner cette position
donc petit récapitulatif général pour
conclure ces finales réaction contre roy
première possibilité le pion cours adam
et le roi ne l'arrêtent pas c'est ce
qu'on appelle le carré du pion donc vous
prenez votre pion vous faites un carré
avec la diagonale tout simplement vous
remarquez si le roi et demi et deux
dents ou n'est pas dedans s'il y est et
bien tant pis vous allez perdre votre
pion
s'il n'est pas dedans vous n'avez plus
qu'à l'avancé à les faire damer gagner
c'est très simple donc ça c'est le cas
où les rois sont éloignés de l'action
deuxième cas le roi est à côté du pion
sur les quatre centrales c'est à dire
sur les colonnes b c d e f ou g
c'est-à-dire toutes les colonnes sauf
les colonne latérale cas général le roi
est à côté du pion si le roi adverse et
devant c'est nul très simplement en
gardant le roi devant reculant comme ça
reculant toujours face aux pions et
prenons l'opposition c'est à dire se
mettre en face au roi a admis des qui
tente une attaque latéral donc la
défense nul sauf si les blancs arrive à
mettre le roi devant le pion à prendre
eux-mêmes l'opposition là il vous
forcera à partir d'un côté ou de l'autre
il va gagner de l'espace il va gagner du
terrain toujours en progressant avec
simplement son roi contre le vôtre et
ensuite il aura plus qu'à avancer ses
pions pour finir en arrivant adam
troisième cas le cas du pion h
donc la très très simple une fois de
plus le phénomène du car et c'est à dire
est ce que le roi et demi peut réussir à
attraper votre pion si oui tant pis
c'est nul vous allez perdre pions sinon
vous allez adam et vous gagnez autre
possibilité qu'ont les deux rois sont
proches de l'action soit il arrive sur
la case f8 la fameuse case clé cette
case qui est je ne sais pas comment dire
mais en gros si vous allez pions h
ces deux colonnes à côté jusqu'à la
promotion sert jusqu'à la vie qui a
mangé
s'il arrive sur cette case là il va
propre profiter des deux stratagème soit
y semer sur les tasses de promotion et
c'est nul on ne peut pas l'en déloger
soit ils veulent en faire votre propre
roi dans la boîte dès 15h c'est th8 les
casses de promotion et la cellule
également donc votre seule solution pour
gagner c'est de mettre le roi angers7
et ensuite de préparer la bourse
éditions h voilà je pense qu'on a fait à
peu près le tour de la question le tour
des finales roi étions contre contre roy
tout simplement donc à peu près 50% de
chances de gain ça dépend de la position
et je vous invite donc à revoir tout ça
pour être bien sûr et savoir jouer ces
finales
mathématiquement est parfaitement sans
réfléchir puisque c'est des finales
quand même élémentaire aux échecs
voilà je vous donne rendez-vous à l'onu